hey I so as we take this right now
president Obama is
great sangria is one of our the allies
in the Gulf but we actually
don't have much in common with them
especially when it comes
to human rights and human rights with in
the borders the country ourselves and we
all
every country has bad thing that I
recorders and in our word
but I want by the women's rights issue
because it's really interesting
and Saudi Arabia right now women cannot
ride
they also week boat supposedly in 2015
believed
can't drive to on season that might be a
problem but I don't be too with that is
ninety tweet this morning something
about this in a couple people from Saudi
Arabia respond to be in there too
they thought were particularly so one
person
said nobody thinks about such a
ridiculous
think that using people getting killed
every day syria iraq
whether that was one interesting way to
sort of deflection it's not really
talking about the same miss you buddy
I it's something is just trying to get a
little inside
and the this way and this looks like a
things about twenty years ago Terry said
there are things that don't need world
including within driving cars
there are a lot accidents let alone me
dry
now courses easy for a you know the
women take it away
where are you going okay I don't I am
NOT one of those people
the United States to know everyone
else's business
it if they have this issue the country
update
figure it out for themselves I don't I
want I don't tell them hey
you should do this not but I don't buy
it is about it
I think it's stupid like all over you
know or
car accident track did you know that
your United States women actually have
a lower premiums archer because they're
actually just
less likely to crash march right now I'm
gonna venture to say that he doesn't
know that all those things your
information hearing more of their
but that's partly also because the
government yesterday and have to keep
you know they keep racial divide device
based on
sex and all that so you really can't
wait you know it when you're a kid
right or work a UN agency he grew up
he grew up hi up again with yeah it's
only
yes the plane but
I just what do you do see nothing
what is the United States do adjust our
country
don't fucked up things and work and to
impart
yeah me that your completely you doing
anything bad its
very possible that both countries have
serious issues
each workout now I wouldn't want Saudi
Arabia tried
be here are trying to tells
should do right now I wonder military
already like that but I V at the same
time
country has issues you need to work all
these really court
right and that of course is the hwy you
too we're
social media all that which
interestingly as doing this right now
being another country in the area I
turkey block user this
I know not actually sings it was
actually all you
showing that the Prime Minister want to
do you like a false flag operation
and what that means is they were going
to in
be either a Turkish your church property
with Syria
it seems as though the series did turkey
be
or hardly working out so serious attack
the country Turkey and the reason why
did not just because it
war usually people will rallied support
the covets there like that george bush
Jack with the whole yapping
yeah so not super she I just I'm so
tired the United States getting
involved in all these things becomes
least when it comes to
any other country I just feel like look
why don't we focus on keeping
our borders safe let's focus on on take
care of our own people
let other countries handle it themselves
mustard ended
USVI I used to not think that way so
much right now has a little
p in our government like our ability to
govern properly see everything
just everyone's buying that how what
right do
he had to tell anyone else anywhere with
you absolute and this was one people
she including 10 ish he's there women's
recent
even blows basic human right just like
me some sort of a sliding
right which we are women the same even
if you don't wanna go to gay the gaping
ass still a bridge too far
cream minute yeah I think should be so
should he see anything
yeah right well I think I think it's
okay to
how share your you dont pretty last week
back east issues is through education so
you going to these countries
out with education with up the tools
necessary to empower the women so they
can
actually defend themselves by sup look
here in the United States
women's suffrage we have another country
minute okay
you need to make sure that women have
the right well know it was a grassroots
movement
really room here United States and that
happened based education our
people Stussy you can do abroad you
don't have to look
militarily your necessarily have to do
it stations
education is really the key its power
that's the wage well said by one of the
smartest girls I know
and a great ride